when we last caught sight of agent dunn
he was departing new york and making his
way to philadelphia
he had not long since witnessed his
friend being brutally murdered by a
mysterious woman dressed in black
then while on his mission to hunt her
down he discovered the significance of
this woman was much greater than he
could have imagined
and that there is something much bigger
in play
it turned out she'd been working with
rogue division agents the lmb
and has access to a surprisingly large
amount of highly sensitive information
around the shd gathering clues
dunn hopes to uncover what she's up to
and who she's working for
and at this stage all intel is pointing
him towards philadelphia
[Music]
[Music]
heather had always been an exceptional
mediator and had dreams of becoming an
entertainment lawyer
but this all changed when a close friend
was killed during a hostage situation
she knew from then on she wanted to make
a difference in the world
to protect and try to prevent the
senseless loss of innocent lives
so she joined the fbi critical incident
response group where she worked on
providing expertise in crisis management
hostage rescue surveillance crisis
negotiations
behavioral analysis and technical
operations
while pursuing this new line of work she
undertook studies at georgetown
university
where she gained a phd in psychology
it was here that she caught the eye of
the strategic homeland division with
their thesis on the catastrophic mindset
she discussed how catastrophic thinking
can be defined as ruminating about
irrational worst-case outcomes
it can increase anxiety and prevent
people from taking action
in a situation where action is required
and this can be especially true in a
crisis situation
because of this paper she was identified
as an incredibly valuable asset to the
shd
and was recruited into their ranks soon
after
as an optimist and highly skilled in
reading the motivations of others
she is conscious of the overall
well-being of a group of individuals
and is highly empathetic
heather ward was defending a settlement
a settlement that was struggling with
everything
from food and clean water to electricity
and illness
and on top of this constant attacks
they had finally made it through winter
and with spring it brought a new taste
of hope
but although things were looking up they
were still far from fine
while hunting turkey on the outskirts of
their encampment isaac suddenly blipped
alerting her that an unknown agent had
just arrived in philadelphia
turning she saw the figure of a man and
who was pointing her weapon towards her
he shouted out a command for her to show
him her watch
she quickly reciprocates and also calls
out her name and credentials to him
he immediately lowers his gun and
identifies himself as caleb dunn
an shd agent from new york city
he is clearly very defensive and doesn't
seem overly trusting of new people
but she needs him to realize that he's
in her city now and she needs to know
who he is
in order to keep her people safe he
begins describing in detail everything
he had witnessed
from the rogue agents back home to the
newly weaponized lmb
he then asked her about the current
situation in philadelphia
she listens to his information carefully
as she is already well aware of the
current situation in new york
as it was the epicenter of the outbreak
she thinks to herself there must be a
good reason why he would be here
rather than new york as philadelphia is
fearing much better
dunn went on to further explain his
altercations with the mysterious woman
in black
and how he had discovered that
philadelphia is somehow connected
however before they could continue any
further with the conversation they heard
gunfire
and it was coming from the settlement
a local group calling themselves the
founders are attacking hither's
settlement
a collection of tyrannical opportunist
gun nuts they believe that the us was
doomed from the beginning
by the flawed ideals of its founding
fathers they want to rewrite the
constitution
with a form of class-based society and
they to be the masters above everyone
else
they had been attacking the settlement
and its people since february
and while hither and the other agents
had thus far managed to hold them back
it seemed with every failed attack that
they were getting stronger
and somehow better armed
heather and dunn arrive at the scene
without a second thought they engaged
the attacking forces
there used to be a sale of three agents
guarding the settlement but over time
these numbers had dropped it was now
just her
and it had been this way for the last
month
fortunately it didn't take long to scare
off the founders by surprising them
and flanking from behind any founders
still standing after the initial barrage
of bullets
quickly fled the scene
heather explained to dunn about how the
settlement originally started out at the
university hospital
but as the settlement began to quickly
grow it started to attract all sorts of
unsavory folk
so because of this they moved to a
location that was easier to defend
at first the founders were just a
nuisance but then a month ago they
started demanding a weekly tribute for
upholding security
initially heather laughed at them
however when they came back with a
mortar and lmgs
along with a number of other shiny new
toys she started to take notice
it was then that dunn explained that
they are having a similar situation in
new york
where a group thought to be crushed and
disbanded suddenly came back
re-armed and re-militarized with a large
number of new weapons and technology
heather was now beginning to understand
and this was the link that he was
talking about earlier
dunn however wants to be certain so he
inquires of the location of the founders
headquarters
heather introduces dunn to a man named
timmy a former member of the founders
who had abandoned their ranks a month
ago
he left after he witnessed one of the
founder leaders execute his friend
initially heather assumed he was there
to spy on the settlement
so took him in and fed him false intel
but over time he proved himself to be
loyal
and an asset to their cause dunn began
to question him
to find out if he knew of a woman with
short black hair and blue eyes
and who was more than likely an outsider
working alongside the founders
tammy confirmed that he'd seen her and
that she is referred to as
mantis he also shared that everything
started changing after her first visit
however he had no more information to
share with them as he had left not long
after that
heather and dunn asked tommy for his
assistance and showing them how to sneak
inside the founder headquarters
and eventually managed to convince them
to go back and show them the way
closer to the founders compound they
head underground using the sewers so
they can get access to the inner
perimeter
once back above ground isaac alerts them
of a database sample match
mantis is here sneaking through the
compound
isaac once again picks up a familiar
burst transmission
they spot an open door where it seems to
be coming from and advance forward
moving quietly they find the source of
the transmissions
two men are in the room sending out
communications on a radio
with a high risk of bringing all the
founders forces down upon them
dunn decides on stealth and pulls out
his crossbow
firing quickly before the enemy even
knows they're there
he strikes them down one in the head and
the other through the neck
once inside the room they look around
and notice that the place is packed full
of weapons
timmy identifies one of the men as a top
leader among the founders
however mantis is nowhere to be seen
although mantis may not be here they
have still found a huge stash of the
founder's weaponry
so before they head off heather and
timmy rigg the room with explosives
meanwhile dunn bags up the radio
equipment and any documentation he can
find
nevertheless eventually the cover is
blown and a siren starts going off
outside they can hear men shouting and
frantically searching for them
with done taking point they quickly
start making their way out of the room
and towards the exit
barely slowing down to fire at the
guards they make it to the inner
perimeter just as the building explodes
dunn instructs the others to make their
way into the sewers while he remains
behind to cover them
but unfortunately timmy is struck down
in the street
and doesn't make it dunn stops to assist
the fallen man
but he's gone
back in the settlement heather is
distraught that their actions have led
to timmy being killed
she wants to blame dunn for his
obsession of this woman and how it had
been put in this situation
dunn confesses to her the reason why he
needs to catch her so badly
that mantis was responsible for the
death of his friend and fellow agent
heather begins to sense as he speaks
that he has absolutely no intention of
catching this mantis woman alive
she adamantly insists to done that
mantis needs to be interrogated
with all those resources documentation
including the secret defense facilities
within the city and the security systems
she can't possibly be acting alone
dunn contacts faye and tells her of the
sakon transceiver radio that they had
found she suggests that he takes it to
fort meade
as the nsa may have a way of decrypting
it
with the founders now out of the picture
heather's protection is no longer
necessary for the settlement
she's ready to get out there and help
others so she insists that she's coming
along with dunn for the journey
plus it'll mean that she's there to
ensure that he doesn't just kill mantis
outright
as soon as he catches sight of her
i'm quite enjoying the comic strips that
have been used in the background to
assist in building the scene when
telling the story
i feel it adds a bit more where some
gameplay just really doesn't cut it
maybe i need to find an artist to help
me out again if you weren't aware this
has been part two
of the division comic book series that
came out at the beginning of the
division two
you can find these on darkhorse.com
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm